what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
I am NOT a patient man I've never been a
patient man I've never had patients from
the time that I was a little kid up
until right now when I want something I
don't want it now I want it right now
like I don't I don't like waiting
I hate waiting on things and I've been
reading through Planet Hulk and I was
like hmm I can't wait to do World War
Hulk sounds like you know we're gonna do
we're gonna cover like everything in
this video I'm planning hope we're gonna
cover all the rest of the stuff that way
we can jump into World War Hulk because
World War Hulk is stupidly good um it is
it's insane how good it is so following
the events of our first video really
like the first volume the plan hook of
end really began - it was really Greg
Pak taking this traditional standard on
a multi-part series in the sense that um
you really had like in the beginning you
basically have the stage being set
that's usually how the first story arc
goes it sets the stage it says hey
here's the status quo and then there
will be some kind of major conflict and
what that conflict will do is it will
eliminate the existing status quo and it
will begin a transition to the new
status quo and that's exactly what
happened in our first video you know to
kind of provide a little bit of a
refresher there for the first video it
was really just the Incredible Hulk
being sent away from the planet Earth by
the Illuminati because he was deemed too
unpredictable he crash-landed on Sekar
he was basically press-ganged into the
gladiatorial games and then eventually
rose up against the Red King alongside
the Silver Surfer now the kicker about
all this is that following the
Incredible Hulk essentially defeating
the immediate armies of the Red King and
going out into saqar proper he of course
had his warbound Korg and alloway and so
on but the idea was that his actions had
inspired open rebellion among everybody
else like all these slaves from across
the planet who were subservient to the
Red King had looked to the Incredible
Hulk as an example of the fact that they
could attain their own freedom whether
it was through force or otherwise and so
in response to this the Red King did the
only thing he knew how to do the Red
King used force in order to try to
maintain his control now the cool thing
about all this was that kyra
his shao
a member of the old strong didn't really
know the full spectrum of everything
that have been going on instead from her
mind she was a child being groomed to
understand how the old power worked out
to be great being groomed to understand
what her place was going to be as a
warrior among her own group the issue
with this was that at some point along
the line when she was a young girl
the spikes had suddenly attacked her
village and it resulted in the Red King
basically you know allowing the conflict
to take place and then turning around
and finding out who she was and then
taking her as his own now what Greg Pak
is doing here is Greg Pak is using a
really cool instance of something called
game theory and it works out really
really well with regards to this story
so game theory is is literally just
using like mathematical probability to
determine the logical action that people
will take a really good example of this
ruckus and this particular instance he's
using something as like a leader so um
to sidetrack for a second a bear with me
here because this may seem kind of out
of left field but let's say that like
you're the leader of a territory all
right let's say you're like the leader
of the United States of whatever your
name is the United States of comics
playing let's say you're the leader of
the United States of Commerce explain
and you learn that another country is
going to attack you well you have three
options are available to you you can let
the attack happen you can stop the
attack beforehand or you can attack them
before they attack you now the idea here
is under normal circumstances attack
them before they attack you or defend
against the attack make preparations to
keep your people safe but if you did
either of those it would alert the enemy
to what it is that you're doing and so
what you can do is you can let the
attack happen and then in turn your
people will rally under you it's it's
one of the concepts of game theory but
the idea here is that the Red King did
exactly that the Red King had a motive
here the Red King was a child he was an
emperor he wasn't really viewed as being
someone that could be an effective
leader and so what he needed was someone
at his side they could basically
maintain the level of protection that he
needed but could also allow him to have
others look to him as a legitimate
leader and by going to one of the oldest
races in the entirety of say cars
history and essentially allowing an
attack on their group to happen and then
turning around and capturing the
strongest of them it forged an
allegiance by force as opposed to you
know diplomacy or something like that
but the basis behind this entire
revelation was that Kiera had learned
that the spikes were implemented by the
Red King himself
despite system we just arrived in her
village and attacked her this has been
orchestrated by the Red King now
something else to point out here is the
red king did not engineer the spikes
instead within the Marvel Universe the
spice existed as basically like a
sentient organism and they literally
just fed on cosmic energy they would
just traverse the spaceways and they
would feed on energy the problem with
this was that during the rule of the red
King's father the spikes had landed and
then were eventually eliminated or
removed from the planet by the red
King's father they were essentially sent
to the moon the problem with this is
that while they stayed in stasis for
some time and they ended up trying to
cannibalism in order to survive the Red
King harnessed the spikes for his own
uses and the Red King basically used the
spikes to essentially get rid of
communities that had worked against him
to get rid of communities that were not
functioning the way that he wanted them
to or not recognizing his rule as being
legitimate but in learning about this
akai era had effectively turned against
the red king she had turned against him
realizing that he was not an ally that
he was an enemy now the lights that he
was willing to go to to try to defeat
those who were standing against him was
a such an extreme that he was actually
willing to wipe out all life on the
planet if it meant that nobody would
challenge him and so because of this
because of the fact that he was so
extreme because he was so dangerous
because of the fact that he had
basically destroyed her people kierra
had turned against the Red King and
allied herself with the Incredible Hulk
and so what happened is Kyra alongside
the Hulk as well as the remnants of the
warbound
basically went through and cut a swath
and I know you guys I know you guys love
it when I say that kind of swath through
the entirety of the red King's army
eventually leading to his defeat now in
this original story the way Greg pack
did it it was presumed that the Red King
had been killed but of course as we
learned with regards to the the origin
of scar himself as The Incredible Hulk
son now the Red King didn't die the Red
King and said was basically beaten to
the edge of death and then eventually
brought back by his own wild BOTS but
what the story does what these events do
is they effectively pick up with the
Incredible Hulk alongside Kiera
essentially creating their own way and
in forming their own Kingdom and the
remnants of the Red Kings rule now the
funny thing about this is with the
Incredible Hulk and Kyra they're almost
one in the same in terms of how they
view things in a sense that kyer has
been raised to be a warrior and so she's
the very definition of a warrior in
truth she's really more akin to Thor
than anybody else but in the confines of
this particular story um she wants peace
to a degree but she's also has no qualms
killing those that get in her way and
The Incredible Hulk is the exact same
way but the other half of this coin is
that when the Incredible Hulk first
showed up on Sekar as part of the Planet
Hulk event he wanted to leave he didn't
want to have anything to do with these
guys here he didn't want to have
anything to do with forming a war bound
or basically leading the inhabitants to
salvation but the way this worked is
that he was viewed as essentially being
thus a Carson that is to say basically
the savior of Sekar whenever he bled it
ended up growing plants on the surface
and so it really allowed these
civilizations that were here to look at
him as quite literally their messianic
figure a guy that was going to lead them
into a much greater tomorrow now
eventually the Incredible Hulk actually
takes this role on alongside with Tiger
and he basically looks at himself as a
king with her as his queen more so than
that he's also met with Meek now the
cool thing about this when it comes to
Meeks character is he basically helped
some of his people who have been held
captive to escape into freedom but in
the process had actually undergone this
transformation basically making him the
king and allowing him to get with their
queen and do what they do in order to
create offspring um the Queen's not much
to look at but it works with the
confines of their own race here but the
other half of this is that they're very
much in the middle of cleaning up here
they're very much in the middle of
getting everything sorted out now with
regards to the conversation between the
incredible Hogan Kyra this is why I say
it's such an important part of his
character is because when he takes her
and they go on somewhat of a journey
where they go to basically like the
steps of the car which is this sort of
proving ground slash you know peaceful a
harmonic place the two of them begin to
talk and The Incredible Hulk says that
all he was bred for is destruction I
mean when when the Incredible Hulk is
just about earth all he did was just
destroy things now again a lot of this
was because the Incredible Hulk wanted
to be left alone but it didn't change
the fact that the Incredible Hulk always
was destructive by nature hits the
reason he was sent away by the
Illuminati
whenever he looks at the entire history
of his time on Sekar he looked at the
events ads they've unfolded throughout
the entire Planet Hulk event all he sees
is a continuation of the pattern that he
had on
and that wherever he goes destruction
will follow him but Kyra looks at him
and says this is not the case you know
when you bleed it grows plant life and
look at the life that you've created
he's basically restore the planet he's
in the process of terraforming the
planet just because of his blood and so
what he's done is he's given all the
civilizations on Sekar hope he's given
them a future to look forward to and
because of this his life while on earth
he may very well have been a force of
destruction on Sekar he's a savior in
every ounce of the world now this is
huge fit Incredible Hulk and this is why
Greg packs riding a Planet Hulk is so
good because we've never really seen an
instance like this as one of reasons why
I love The Incredible Hulk we never seen
him written in such a way to where he
was more of a savior than a destroyer
now a lot of that was because of the
fact that you know within the confines
of his role on earth he was just kind of
a bumbling buffoon that was he was a
bull in a china shop that's really the
best way to describe the Incredible Hulk
on earth and it worked in a lot of
situations because we got to see him go
against some various you know heroes and
you know even more so with villains it
was kind of like well if things aren't
going our way calling the Hulk he'll
solve our problem then we'll send him
away it was it was really interesting in
how it was done but it didn't add a lot
of character depth the most death we
ever really got was during Peter David's
run when it came to the Incredible Hulk
history his abusive father so on and so
forth and why the whole persona
manifested when banner was blasted with
gamma rays but that was about it there
was really no huge exploration into his
character the cool thing about this
though is that we get that in this story
we get so much depth with regards to the
incredible Hawks the AI gets to such an
extreme that he actually changes his
tune you know he tells Kai oh yeah
you're right you know I am a savior here
I am a person here that can literally
lead all these different races to a much
better tomorrow and so he alongside Kyra
and everybody else here begins the
process of cleaning up because the
process of getting things sorted out now
what we also learned is that there is
some trouble in paradise you know there
are individuals that look at the
Incredible Hulk
Loa especially and says he's not that
different from the Red King the Red King
used us as slaves to build his kingdom
and it seems like the incredible Hawks
doing the same thing now we as the
reader know this is not the case all we
know is that the Incredible Hulk is just
making them apply a little bit of elbow
grease and that is really one of these
situations where everybody has to chip
in in order to make everything better
you know it's not something where the
can just fix everything moreso than that
there's a reward to this you know once
they finish rebuilding once they finish
clearing all this debris out once they
finish restructuring and making the
kingdom their own they can sit back at
their handiwork and say this is ours
you know something earned is far more
significant than something given and so
the idea here is that they're
effectively earning their place in this
kingdom they're earning the right to say
we made this as opposed to well we just
topple the red king everything stayed
intact and then we just occupied the
kingdom it really establishes them as
being part and parcel into this entire
area itself and so from here we really
have this kind of conclusion with
regards to the idea of the spikes and
this really just kind of ties and it's
really just Greg pack you know
eliminating these last few things in the
sense that these various spike ships
that have been confined to the moon that
hadn't quite been harnessed by the Red
King which ultimately led to the
Incredible Hulk traveling to the moon
and freeing all the spikes and allowing
them to go back about their business not
traversing the space way so it's
literally just kind of him fulfilling
these last few packs fulfilling these
last few agreements you know solidifying
the fact that the Incredible Hulk is a
true legitimate and benign leader over
the people in in Sekar the problem with
this is that as they begin to celebrate
once everything begins to get put
together you know once everything begins
to come back to normal we let me find
that this is the ship with a shuttle
that the Incredible Hulk had been
brought in begins to start beeping now
the idea was to turn this shuttle into
somewhat of a monument to basically make
it a testament to the fact that the
Incredible Hulk had been sent here as a
sacar s'en he had liberated them all and
ushered them in the freedom and because
of the fact that this thing starts to
beeping we basically learned that this
is a warp core meltdown that the nuclear
core of this ship is beginning to break
down it's beginning to detonate and so
the incredible hope does what he can to
try to protect those around him you know
especially Kyra who's currently pregnant
with their child but the result is that
there's really nothing he can do this
nuclear powered really bombed for lack
of a better word essentially explodes
and it destroys everything in the crown
city everything and almost everyone the
only people who want killed here are
those individuals those people who are
part of his warbound a hero Emcore those
people who basically sent away from the
crown city in order to begin the process
of creating diplomatic ties with other
civilizations other tribes around the
planet in order to ensure that they you
know that they don't really recognize
the Incredible Hulk as
King so much as they see him as the new
ruler of crown City and someone with
which they can have diplomatic relations
with and so because they're not
currently present they become aware of
what's going on they realize that the
crown cities been destroyed in a nuclear
blast but for them they don't know why
they don't really understand why but the
more important thing about this is Greg
Pak is setting the stage here with the
Incredible Hulk as a character and this
this is one of the reasons why I loved
the the end of Planet Hulk so much
because this is why I say there's so
much development with the Incredible
Hulk as a character all he's known is
disappointed I mean that's the story of
his life let down after let down
superheroes claim to be his friends and
then they betray him villains use him
for their own ends humanity's constantly
hunting him down the incredible hooks
life was just nothing but a sad tale you
know Bruce banners father was an
extremely abusive man's you know more so
to the point that is believed that bruce
banner himself develop multiple
personalities and so when he was blasted
with the gamma bomb that led to the
formation of the incredible hulk the
incredible hulk is just the physical
manifestation of his anger towards his
father his rage against humanity
you know his hatred against all things
or anything that would try to do harm
against banner himself it's really like
a physical manifestation of his
psychological desire to stay protected
from everything in the world that would
harm him and so the idea is that leaving
earth and being sent on Sekar for the
first time gave the Incredible Hulk
purpose it gave him a place that he
believed he can call his own and The
Incredible which says this you know he
says look when I was here I thought I
had a place I I believed this could be
something real I believed it could be
something true I believed that I could
really look out onto the horizon of a
Rising Sun and see a better tomorrow but
he says I was foolish to believe this I
was foolish to believe that I would find
anything but death and destruction
everywhere I go now as we know with our
origin story of scar this was the moment
where by kyra had basically sent her
unborn son into the planet in order to
basically be saved from the presumed
destruction of sakaar
and he would essentially emerge and so
these last few moments of the Incredible
Hulk on this planet are around the time
that his son is emerging and beginning
to come into his own in terms of
encountering these various species and
so on that are part of the planet itself
part of the indigenous life but then
suddenly the Incredible Hulk is also met
with the remainder of his warbound with
court hero in meek so on
initially the Incredible Hulk wants to
be left alone because he's quite
literally a grieving guy here but as we
know with the stages of grief at first
its denial
its denial of the fact that those
individuals around that we lose are dead
it's the idea what don't you know
somehow something will happen things
will change we can get things back to
the way they were before after that it
leads to anger and this is the
Incredible Hulk angry
this is him about as mad as he's ever
going to be and so he along side with
his warbound prepare they prepare for an
invasion of Earth they begin the process
up forming arms and armament for full-on
invasion and destruction of those who
did the Incredible Hulk harm and so in
effect at the beginning of world war
hulk the end of the Planet Hulk
storyline what we have here is Bruce
Banner with the wrath of God it is God
is a sight to behold
do I almost want to just like crank out
wood we're hope right now like oh like
this this is man this is oh can you guys
feel it can you feel the excitement like
this is this I love this story so much
because really Planet Hulk is just like
one giant prelude to World War Hulk but
at the same time like I was in The
Incredible Hulk scorner the entire event
I mean let's let's have this little bit
of a discussion about what work on for a
second I was in the incredible Hawks
corner with regards to World War Hulk I
was an aside because I was like yeah man
like humanity's done nothing but dick
you over Incredible Hulk let's get some
revenge dude let's kill some folks let's
go ahead and remind humanity of their
place in the bigger picture like let's
remind them where they stand because
it's not on an even playing field with
you man like I was I was like let's do
this but uh because I'm so hyped we're
gonna go ahead and cover World War Hawk
in the next video we'll go ahead and
just kick off world war hold but uh but
yeah guys like I really hope you all
enjoyed this Planet Hulk series so far
um there are a few things here and there
that we didn't really cover I know
there's gonna be some people who want
some of that stuff covered we may or may
not do that a future point in time but
in truth it wasn't really relevant to
the story per se um it was really just
someone we could kind of gloss over and
then get to the meat and potatoes of
Planet Hulk because I kind of think the
stuff that we ran over in this video was
far more significant in terms of the
development of the Hult because again my
aim here was to basically show you guys
the
illusion of Bruce Banner from being sent
to earth residing on Planet Hulk the
things he gained and then interned lost
and why he's so angry and why he ends up
coming back to earth and literally
waging a one-man war against the
superheroes of the planet but with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end and if you guys are new here
to comics explain be sure to hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
drop a like and leave a comment down
below and I will catch you all later
peace
you